we talk about having multiple sexual
partners or too many sexual partners has
been a problem for long-term successful
relationships but what you're basically
saying here is that because of your past
experiences you met a good guy but you
wasn't able to treat him right because
of your Trauma from your previous
relationship so doesn't that then come
inside with the fact that women should
have less sexual partners to alleviate
themselves from these traumas well no
because I just I don't think that
alleviates women from
so because wow
experiences have led to current traumas
so if you had less Partners obviously
this is your first boyfriend but in most
cases you know the more Partners you
have the more likely you are for these
sort of situations